look i know you're new here so let me  catch you up  everything you love about earth is gone  your skinny no foam vanilla latte gone  binge watching gone carbs love songs the  grand canyon ruined  okay that didn't change much but say  goodbye to surprise parties ketchup and  mustard late night tests taco tuesdays  and if that wasn't enough  puppies  or  [Music]  not the puppies i know right who does  that i mean i'm more of a cat guy but  still where was that everything is gone  except for the last city and now a  psycho rhino named gaul has come to take  that away too so it's time to bring out  the big guns  it's not a metaphor guys go grab some  big guns  because if we're going down we're going  down fighting do it for the tower and  the ramen shops do it for the loop  they've taken from us but most  importantly do it for the puppies  uh  follow that guy  [Music]  [Music]  i am so proud  of myself right now  destiny 2 available september 6th  play on ps4 pro  you